[موسيقى]
هل تتذكرون عامل الاطلاع او النقاش المصري
الذي اسر القلوب على منصات التواصل بغنائه
لاغنيه الطرب الراحله ورده المطرب احمد
سالم الذي فتحت له الابواب بمقطع غنائي
مصور بالهاتف كان من المفترض ان يشارك
مسرح دار الاوبرا المصريه مع الفنانه
اصاله ضمن حفل ختام رجانا الموسيقى
العربيه لكن في لحظات الاخيره يستبعد احمد
من الغناء وينشر فيديو يؤكد فيه ان
استبعاده كان سببه عدم استكمال الاوراق
المطلوبه لكن القصه تاخذ منحا اخر عندما
وراء المناع الموسيقى حلمي بكر رئيس
اللجنه التحضيريه لمهرجان الموسيقى
العربيه والذي قال اين تقاليد الغناء في
الاوبرا وشروطها لا تنطبق على المطرب
النقاش لن يعود قليلا الى قصه النقش
مقطع عفوي لنقاش يغني اثناء عمله في ضوء
جدران احدى الشقق التقطه بنفسه ثم قرر ان
نشره على قناته عبر يوتيوب في سبتمبر 20
20 دون اي مونتاج او مؤثرات مقطع لن يشرحه
لك يوتيوب لكن ربما تنصفه الخوارزميات اذا
بحثت عن الاغنيه الاصليه التي كان يدندنها
بكره يا حبيبي لورده الجزائريه بعد نحوي
عامين من نشره يقرر احد المستخدمين انتشال
هذا المقطع من غباره الافتراضي ويعيد
احيائه على فيسبوك لتبدا القصه احمد سالم
المطرب النقاش كما يلقبه الاعلام يستيقظ
ليجد تفاعلا هائلا على المقطع الذي نسي
انه نشيئه وما زاد من حيرته تفاعل الفنان
رامي جمال وبعده بانه سيشاركه الغناء او
حتى يساعده على انتاج البون كامل يترك
احمد ادواته التي يفتخر بها ولا يزعجه
لقمه الفني المرتبط بها ويركز في مسيرته
جديده يلتقي بالصحه وينتقل من برنامج لاخر
ويقيم اول حفل في مسرح سقيه عبد المنعم
الصاوي ويستعد للغناء مع الفنانه اصاله
بحفلها في دار الاوبرا المصري
وبعد تحضيرات وبروفات جماعه اصاله بالمطرب
الشاب يستبعد احمد من الحفل بسبب عراقي
المفاجئه وانقسم الناس حول القرار وتتولى
اطراف عديده مهمه الدفاع عنه ويكتفي احمد
بعباره بسيطه على حسابه دون الضجيجا ولد
ضجه الحمد لله وربنا شايل لنا الاحسن
بكره يا حبيبي
نحلو صار
لا لا لا لا
بكره يا حبيبي نحضن
[موسيقى]
القمر
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
بكر اهلا بك الموسيقى حلم
اكبر موسيقيين المصريين والعرب اهلا بك
اهلا بك يا فندم
القضيه والقول بان القوى المحافظه
والاشاره واضحه اليكم السيد حلمي بانها
منعت احمد سالم او المطرب النقاش من
الغناء على مسرح الاوبرا بحجه عدم استكمال
اوراق وايضا بدعه بريستيج الاوبرا كيف
تردون
[موسيقى]
الى احمد سالم واعجبت بصورته وحسيت ان في
طعم جديد في حياتنا بعد فوضى اغاني
المهرجان قلت ده هيكون بدايه جميله جدا ان
احنا نرجع لاصولنا الغنائيه خلاص بعد كده
في اللجنه التحضير ايه حطينا برامج اللي
هي اعلن عنها طول البرنامج وللاسف كان
نفسي الاعلام يتكلم عن عن المهرجان من
اوله لاخره مش عن حاله
احب اقول
ان لما اتحط اصاله لم تعلن اصاله ناسا
وبدو تشرق
الاستاذ احمد سالم
اداره المهرجان ما كانش عندها علم فجاه
الاداره المرجان لقيت بيتعمل بروفا فطلبت
منه بعض اوراق ويجي يقابل على اساس يسجل
ويبقى ليه مكان داخل الاوبرا راح اختفى ما
جاش ثم
اصاله حصل حوار ما بينها وما بين الاداره
المهرجان ان هكذا طب اخبرينا طب قولي لنا
طب احنا قلنا له تعالى طب كل شيء فالك
طبعا هتصرف هذا التصرف نتج عنه انه ما
طلعش مش من اداره المهرجان ولكن صاحب
التصرف هو فضل انه يبتعد عن المشاكل او
انه اعتقد ان هناك في مشاكل فلم يحضر
الحفل الموسيقى
لماذا منع من ذلك
لم يمنع حد ولكن اداره الاوبرا يجب ان
يكون عندها علم ان مش حفل عامله متعاه
حفلات لحفل اكاديميه بتعملها فلازم اداره
المهرجان تتعرف لان كان في سباق قبل كده
وطلع انسان قدم اعمال كانت 30 كلم لما كلم
سيدنا الوزيره قلت لها مين واقف على ان ده
يقوم بالاعمال دي لانك عباره عن مهزله
موسيقيه فكان على الاقل اداره المهرجان
يبقى عندها علم مين جاي يغني ما كانش
عندهم علم الا فجاه اتعمل بروفه وبعد كده
رغم هذا قالوا له طب ابقى تعالى يوم كذا
عشان عايزينك كذا ما جاءش ان فيه الحفله
هتتعمل وهم ما يعرفوش مين اللي طالع يغني
انما حلم بكر ما لوش دخل ان احد المعجبين
بصوته يبقى ازاي هم نوعه ولكن الاداره لها
بروتوكول هي حره فيه مش انا مين الاخم
اسمي عشان يتقال ان انا قلت ما يغنيش
طيب يعني اتهامات الطبقيه
والنظره الاستعلائيه التي وجهت المهرجان
غير صحيحه
وبذوق العلمي ما حدث لصالح احمد سالم هذا
اللقط وهذه الاثاره هتمهدوا بان الجمهور
يلتفت اليويو ويبقى له كيان يبقى اذا دي
اصبحت احد الاساليب الفرقعه اللي ممكن
تمهد للمطرب انه يغني وينجح اذا قدم
الاعمال اللي هو احمد
طب وايه اللي يمنع ان يكون ليه توفر في
نظام اداري ده في نظام للاوبرا يجب ان
يتابع اذا كان احد المطربين الكبار لم
يتبع النظام
اسمه من اكبر مطربين ليه لان في
بروتوكولات للاوبرا لازم ان تنفذ اينما
بكر منعوا ولا الاوبرا منعته ولا اصاله
اصاله تشكر انها حادثه بمطرب عايزه تقدمه
ويبقى اضافه لفقرتها انما لما ادوله
داخل مغني
تجربه قبل كده ومش هاقول اسم مين اللي كان
سبب وكانت الدنيا مقلوبه طب لسه دي ولا
ايه
تمام شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره موسيقى
الكبير حلمي بكر شكرا جزيلا
ومن الرياض ينضم لناقد الفني طارق الشناوي
سيد طارق اهلا ودنا تدخل في نقاش مباشر مع
السيد حلمي لكن كيف ترد عليه
[موسيقى]
ولا يستطيع احد ان يقلل من انجازه ولكن هو
بيتنا هو نفسه قال
والصحافه نشرت انه قال هي اصاله عايزه
تعمل ترند واللي هو منعها من الترند يقصد
احمد سالم
[موسيقى]
هو بس هو ساعات يتلاقى 180 درجه انه هو
لسه محتاج لتدريبات عشان يطلع على الاوبرا
دلوقتي انا شايف بيتراجع عطيه و80 ده
الصوت اللي هو قال عليه لا محتاج لتدريبات
ساحه الجميع الحقيقه انه البروفات تمت
الاوبرا المصريه مش في بيت اصاله ولا في
ستوديو خاص هي تعمل له مش ممكن حد يعمل
بروفات في دار الاوبرا عريقه زي الاوبرا
المصريه هو من غير ما يبقى في معروف مين
ده او هيعمل ايه هو بيقول لم يستكمل
الاوراق او انه ما جاءش ده ده هو منعنع
يوم الافتتاح يعني مثلا لو قلنا كان قصدي
يوم الغناء لو قلنا النهارده كانت يوم
الاربع
فالخميس منى طب ده هو هيبقى اكثر واحد
حريص على انه يخلص اوراقه مش انه يتعرب من
ان هو يقدم اللي هم عايزينه هيبقى اسمه
بتاعي يعني حاجات كده
تفاصيل يعني بسيطه واللي عايز اقوله كمان
حاجه مهمه في اي حفله في الدنيا بيحصل هو
اولا مش جاي يغني منفردا لا بيحصل فقره
كده بانه مثلا حد يطلع على المسرح موجود
في الصاله وده حصل حتى بالصدفه في حفله
اصاله انه في بنت طلعت واا حضنتها ممكن
الاثنين كانوا
وبعدين قالت لها انت بتحب الغناء قالت لها
انا بحب اغني وبغني لكن انا بتغني يعني
اصل انا طلبت منها ان تغني هل اخذت اذن
الاوبرا اكيد لا البنت بس كل الحكايه همم
اتكسفت فنزلت من على المسرح بعد ما كان
ممكن هي دي فقره يعني ايه في جزء كده
بيبقى مش شرط يبقى منظم 100% هو الرغم ذلك
ال همم
الراجل حضر برباب داخل الاوبرا المصريه بس
اللي انا شايفه انه حلمي تراجع 180 درجه
وده كويس
هل انت ترى ان الاوبرا يمكن ان تكون مصرحا
للمبتدئين
[موسيقى]
اللي هم عنده بذره موهبه مؤكد من حقهم ان
يصعد مش يعمل حفله ممكن يبقى فيه فقره
يعني ممكن محمد منير يقدم احد مثلا همم
راغب علامه يقدم حد انا شايف ان ده ويبقى
انا متحمل يعني انا ك- كمطرب كبير ستار
همم زي كاظم زي راغب زي اصاله ايا كان
الاسماء الكبيره اللي موجوده في عالمنا
العربي كله يتحمل المسؤوليه الادبيه ويبقى
نوع من الدعمه بعد كده ينطلق خاصه ان
المطرب ده غنى قبل كده في همم
ففي الصاوي ودي ودي
مكان يعني محترم جدا وبيغني اغاني راسينه
واغاني يعني وحتى لما بقول بكره يا حبيبي
انا شايف وكانه بيتكلم عن نفسه يعني اول
علاقه مع الجمهور لما غنى بكره غنوه ورده
وتلحين البرتقال العظيم كمال الطويل قالها
باسلوبه وكانه يكون ايضا بكره يحلو السهر
ونحضر القمر بيقولوا لنفسه فانا رايي ان
القادم بالنسبه له افضل وانا سعيد بانه
حلمي بكر بيتراجع عن اقواله لان اقواله
مسجله ومكتوبه وكلها اتهام كلها اتهامات
الحقيقه وهو كان متحمل مسؤوليه هو انت
راجع قال الاوبرا لا هو قبل كده بيقول انا
مش ممكن وحاجات كده فانا مبسوط انه يعني
بيعود
للقراءه الصحيحه ماشي شوفي السيد حلمي همم
بده يرد عليك شكرا جزيل الشكر الناقد
الفني طارق الشناوي
هل تترغب في الرد على ما قاله طارق
الشناوي يعرف ان انا عمري
قبل منه انا سمعت فيديو واشد به ولكن نظام
الاوبرا لو عمل بورما في الاوبرا وفوقه
اداره الاوبرا بتتعمل بروفا من غير ما
يكون عندها علم واساله اداره الاوبرا
واساله لجنه التحضيريه فقالوا له ابني
احنا موافقين طب تعال قابلنا فيه في ميعاد
يوم كذا
يا استاذ طارق
شكرا جزيلا لكم